dsk sort des retombées immédiates afin
de r&d
je pense que le risque et en guinée
minimes par rapport au potentiel je
pense qu'on doit comme société avoir des
projets structurants comme sa folie
contre l'iran d'avoir un personnel
alors ne choisirons choisi un mystère ce
projet alors été structuré ya des
risques
je pense que des bénéfices incroyables
ici à québec on retrouve sébastien
bourgault le pdg de l'entreprise flying
wild ce monsieur bougon bonsoir bonsoir
d'abord expliqué nous à quoi ça sert ses
grands ballons ces dirigeables ces
baleines volante
alors avant tout c'est il faut avoir en
tête que ça n'a rien à voir avec les
dirigeables du siècle dernier
c'est un petit peu comme si aujourd'hui
vous refusiez des tramways vous n'allez
pas vous inspirer des vieux tramway en
beaux arts de san francisco ou si elon
musk fait des voitures électriques qui
s'inspire pas des voitures électriques
du siècle dernier
ensuite la particularité c'est que la
seule machine aujourd'hui qui est
capable de faire du point à point c'est
à dire de s'affranchir de toute
infrastructure ou tout obstacles
géographiques
c'est l'hélicoptère et l'hélicoptère est
limitée à 5 tonnes aujourd'hui et grâce
à cette machine on va pouvoir monter à
60 tonnes dans des coûts beaucoup plus
bas et avec une empreinte
environnementale extrêmement faible donc
en résumé c'est une machine qui va être
capable de transporter des charges
lourdes jusqu'à 60 tonnes à peu près
n'importe où de les extraire depuis
n'importe où et ça reste un projet pour
l'instant n'y a pas d'acheteur encore si
alors nous avons le programme m français
est bâti déjà sur les besoins de son
client en france l'office national des
forêts c'est pour eux qu'on développe
cette solution l'office est d'ailleurs
actionnaires de fly wells
par ailleurs une fois qu'on en a compris
le potentiel de cette solution nous
avons signé en france tout un tas
d'accord avec des grands acteurs de
l'éolien des grands acteurs de
l'électricité aux tensions avec des
acteurs du transport exceptionnel qu'est
ce qu'un des commandes fermes
alors là la façon dont les
les clients finaux s'engage sur des
programmes comme ça c'est en entrant au
capital ce qui est encore plus fort
parce qu'une commande ferme vous en
faites ce que vous voulez vous pouvez
toujours l'annuler donc on a préféré la
solution de l'entrée au capital
c'est exactement comme la chine la chine
est entrée au capital parce que nous
sommes intéressés par ce marché pas pour
développement technologique puisqu'il
n'y a pas d'entreprises chinoises dans
le consortium industriel et enfin au
canada on a commencé par faire une étude
de marché pour confirmer avant de
confirmer l'investissement du
gouvernement du québec
et aujourd'hui on a identifié énormément
de potentiel est exactement comme en
france on va commencer maintenant a
signé des ententes avec des acteurs
locaux avec qui qui seraient les
acheteurs potentiels chez nous alors
typiquement c'est d'abord les acteurs du
bois
vous avez par exemple en colombie
britannique on n'est pas au québec là
mais en colombie britannique
de plus en plus de difficultés à aller
chercher du bois dans des endroits
reculés à cause du réchauffement
climatique qui rend les seuls bout et
c'est les grands acteurs industriels qui
ont besoin de transporter des grosses
pièces c'est les acteurs de l'éolien
vous n'avez pas encore énormément au
québec mais ça devrait se développer
ce sont les acteurs du dès lors que vous
avez un transport lourd avec des
difficultés d'accès on travaille
aujourd'hui sur une solution pour les
maisons du plan d'or vous savez qu'il ya
des besoins considérables plus deux à
trois mille maisons préfabriquées pour
les faire sonner chez les premières
nations et donc typiquement on développe
des solutions qui vont permettre
d'accéder à cela et donc on va fabriquer
cela si tout va bien là combien coûte à
l'achat le prix et quel est le prix d'un
dirigeable comme ça alors le prenne un
dirigeable comme ça c'est de l'ordre de
25 millions donc vous voyez que c'est à
peu près 10 fois moins qu'un aéronef
classique de dollars casting de nom
d'euros pardon mais 30 millions d'euros
dont 40 millions de dollars canadiens
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
le programme flying wells
c'est à la fois un constructeur
flinguage industries est un opérateur
une compagnie aérienne fly well services
6 est en fait la nouvelle série 6 mha
vendre des journées de dirigeables donc
le client final
imaginons demain
par exemple si hydro québec avait besoin
de cette solution va payer des journées
d'utilisation à flins guen service il
n'est pas prévu qu'ils achètent des
machines est ce qui s qu'hydro québec a
démontré de l'intérêt travailleurs alors
on n'a pas commencé les démarchages
commerciaux 1 on a d'abord construit le
partenariat avec hydro québec
moi j'ai rencontré un certain avec
pardon le gouvernement moi j'ai
rencontré un certain nombre d'acteurs et
on va travailler ensemble à développer
les solutions exactement comme on l'a
fait avec les grands opérateurs français
parmi parmi vos actionnaires il ya la
société d'état chinoise avic aviation
industry corporation of china qui est
soupçonné d'espionnage industriel aux
etats unis chez geely mais est ce que ça
ne vient pas de nuire pesé sur la
crédibilité de votre groupe d'être
associés à cette entreprise là n'ont
absolument pas d'abord ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que avic et 20 des grands
groupes aéronautiques dans le monde
parmi les cinq ou les dix premiers et
avic à des coopérations avec absolument
tous les acteurs on a eu avec bombardier
à +25 coopération avec airbus en france
et vous imaginez bien car mu par exemple
est extrêmement attentive à ces sujets
de propriété intellectuelle donc il ya
eu des problèmes avec les américains
mais c'est un grand groupe
sérieux ça c'est la première chose
et la deuxième chose c'est que notre
approche a été comment adresser la chine
qui est le deuxième marché du monde et
s'assurer de pouvoir et commercialiser
nos machines avant que les chinois le
fassent eux mêmes c'est exactement la
stratégie mais est-ce qu'il régnait pas
d'avoir une forme de difficultés à avoir
accès au marché américain a un an vous
associer à cette société chinoise non je
pense pas parce que d'abord cette
société chinoise est complètement
minoritaires ensuite il n'y a pas de
société chinoise qui participe au
consortium industriel et les américains
sont extrêmement pragmatiques
c'est à dire que si cette solution leur
permet de faire des choses qu'ils ne
peuvent pas faire autrement et encore
une fois c'est ça qui est intéressant
il n'y a pas une machine au monde qui
est capable de faire du poi points en
dizaines de tonnes
à partir de là il n'y a aucune raison
que ce programme qui encore une fois est
contrôlé par la france de façon
absolument certaine
par ailleurs la chine a donné une
exclusivité mondiale à flyway c'est à
dire que la chine s'est interdite dans
développer autrement que par le biais de
flingues wells
à partir de là il n'y a pas tellement de
raison que le marché américain nous
serons fermés monsieur beaugrand merci
beaucoup pour cet entretien ce soir je
vous en prie